The other participants in the meeting are the reviewers.
These ae the people responsible for raising the issues. Not to say that the,
the moderator or the recorder or the reader can't list some issues,
but their, their primary focus is going to be on their other, on,
on their individual roles, whereas the reviewers, the job here is to do
exactly that. To review the artifact and to point out raise, raise issues.
Typically a meeting will have three to six reviewers, fewer run the risk of
not having enough eyes on the target and more can be overkill.
Right not being effective as far as the, the time invested in, and the number of
defects found. Reviewers should raise issues by asking questions, as opposed to
saying that's a problem. They should not explicitly suggest improvements, but
rather ask if the author thought about doing things in an alternative fashion.
The viewer should not blatantly assert defects, but
ask what would happen under different circumstances.
By taking a questioning attitude, the team can productively raise issues without
getting diverted by emotionally driven debates.